non
allez les ventes 1h21 on en dirait que
juste après y aura donc été mon avis
très très lourd avec cookie poux qui ont
râlé très vite didou déjà ce côté là
tout de suite ma chérie coucou et bien
j'ai une petite vidéo parce qu'en fait
je suis très contente de vos
chroniqueurs gtc vraies cueillies mais
de la meilleure des manières sa voix est
chaud au coeur vraiment je propose qu'on
regarde tout de suite les a et vous aime
bien
ah oui mais regardez la soie poker salut
si oui pour rencontrer un jour pour qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle va vous avoir dans le plus matthieu
delormeau vous avoir dans le pif à cause
d'eux j'ai une foi de quoi maintien
coûte vraiment je tarde de belles jeunes
filles je crois que je me reconnais pas
ma voie et c'est pas mon genre de dire
ces mots la voix sympathique balle hors
du coup pêche et plein de dossiers et
allez on va commencer au hasard allez on
va commencer par matthieu lamy que l'ami
des stars
la salle ami des stars pour saboter des
missions peppers tous les vendredis on
peut dire c'est que toutes les stars
savent qu'ils vous êtes actionnaire
vachement vous appréciez vous ce noble à
peine 1 mathieu que le charisme
guigou oui c'est ça la junior bent alors
attendez donc un vrai celui-là tu as
changé
tiens mais d'ici là les mecs attendre
mai
syrie
[Musique]
suivre
guigou et
bientôt je donnais ahmed mémette la
série anouar ahmed ou courtes jusqu'aux
classes à votre avis est il plus dans
cette édition
tambours et bannissez quoi sur 10 ans
d'âge
messieurs qui courent kalou vendeur mais
quel lourd dont l'adoption de ma peau
qui est oui pendant ce temps là il y en
a qui passent leur temps à se chercher
se chahuter se bagarraient et puis se
faire des petits bisous bref vous êtes
des femmes ce kit vous si rubavu vous
voici le premier épisode des aventures
de baba et casta
[Musique]
la tête
et là c'est un bouffon va
juste ça j'espère juste
facebook étant
pourrait bien compter vos excuses moi on
réforme est votée j'aurai tout le monde
s'inquiète pas
voilà comme teboul avait pris contre moi
a plein de trucs je vais pas faire de
vous des maisons juin chez toi ce week
end je te [ __ ] tard
[Musique]
fait toujours de toi l'ami mais tu fais
là je me tiens cherouati jeu
m
[Musique]
c'est joli c'est le je t'aime à moosch
est très mignon au poker oui ils font
surtout le regard de la faim cyril je
commence à vous connaître
je sais que quand vous faites ce genre
de regard ben généralement vous préparez
une seule vengeance non basson la jama
allez c'est cadeau c'est pour vous c'est
les images que vous n'auriez jamais dû
voir
je veux remercier pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pourrai manger mais c'est rien c'est
rien c'est vous dire j'ai des grands
clips des grands pantalon le rabat
proposé que des bonnes choses c'est que
les boîtes non mais franchement secondes
et moi je sais que du naturel
ces familles ça va c'est sans gluten
merci merci beaucoup à l'hôpital mais
bon je vous rassure pour mon grand
plaisir mon plus grand plaisir vous
n'êtes pas la seule victime de cette
nouvelle manif cyril autres gardés à gta
qui attend qu'elle j'adore non maquis de
l'ordre n'ont sinon attention moi les
claviers
il y maintenant 2 c'est pas moi ce
portable ça qui ça c'est à toi
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous dès 20h10
et qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que j'ai
remarqué qu est ce que j'ai apporté
pendant la bulle j'ai remarqué que
matthieu delormeau avait son portable
eh oui
et voilà donc forcément j'ai dû lui
complicité oui et et vous l'avez vu ou
du cou joli
dans un endroit sûr taha
par ici depuis les sur ma table de nuit
a été couché pas été lavé oui c'est bon
ce moment je trouve que benjamin ce soir
ont particulièrement fort ouais comme
s'ils avaient pris des cours avec le
plus grand maître kung fu du monde c'est
vrai on se regarde tous fous baba h je
savais pas ça c'est quoi ce qu'une femme
à barbe à la figure
[Musique]
bois
[Applaudissements]
c'est voter nous trahit un peu méchant
mais je vous adore c'est que de l'amour
et franchement c'est mignon pukki non ça
c'est pas mignon et n'ont qu'un effet
peut-être theron ma poule 1 ah bah oui
je ne sais pas je voudrais je n'aurais
pas chez toi pour le relevé est vrai
pour cyril vous avez tous les talents 1
c'est voir moi depuis trois semaines je
vous regarde vous savez faire tout à
wayne presque tout et c'est pas jean mis
à votre premier fan qui me contredira
cyril vous êtes aussi un imitateur way
we regarde on apprécie mais on savoure
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au boulot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je lui bouffe nous voulons vivre en paix
alors alors oui je ne voulais pas se
bouffer comme moi et alors blue et leur
mépris retient l'après-midi retient nous
a fait une partie de ses fans aux quatre
ans
pas possible la faille au paille pas
possible a failli au paille d'autres
choses ma peau
bien sûr la semaine dernière cyril vous
allumiez emprunt m engage à charles
aznavour qui a cartonné d'ailleurs
félicitations merci merci mais vous avez
dû arrêter tmp 20 minutes plus tôt que
d'habitude et je peux vous assurer que
vos chroniqueurs en vrai bosseur il ya
quelques semaines mémoire kbit pour
chroniqueur au vrai bosseur il était
triste forcément très très tristes en
800 s'arrête sordo on a les images
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une honte t'inquiète pas y
aura-t-il y aura des sanctions nous
allons continuer même on a d'autres
choses maps ou pas oui tiens parlons de
sanctions je peux vous dire que l'heure
est grave la guerre falloir sévir dans
ses rues cyril il est vraiment temps de
sortir la grosse latry grosse la très
très très très grosse voix lors de leur
match dantesque va en avoir besoin
vous pouvez me rappelais autour de la
table quelle est la règle numéro 8 de
cyril pas de portable pas de portable en
plateau et bien après à moi j'ai bien
l'impression que cette nouvelle règle
n'a jamais jamais existé et pas plus
tard qu'il ya trente minutes en plus
quoi vous allez des activités
[Musique]
c'est beau
je vois la vie lundi
celui qui vivait avec son portable en
plateau ils restent dehors c'est clair
c'est simple c'est net et si je vois un
portable maintenant la personne sort si
vous voyez des gens qui sont plus là au
bout d'un moment donné vous saurez
pourquoi on a quoi d'autre une petite
dernière de la table il ya des
chroniqueurs qui bossent énormément
bon je n'ai pas encore trouvé mais et
demi il ya ceux qui sortent du lot enfin
surtout un qui a toujours ses fiches à
la main bosseur de l'extrême ce qu'ils
savaient de qui je parle le plus gros
bosseur autour de la table mais bien sûr
j'en ai jamais revus
mais oui battant décès d'ironie quand
même bien pas besoin vos méninges en
revanche quand il bosse c'est à dire un
jour dans l'année
eh bien il faut absolument que tout le
monde le sait ch
[Musique]
cette fois ci je ne sais pas ça tombe
très bien ce que j'avais une vidéo que
je gardais sous le coach voulait déjà
van trier à table aujourd'hui sur une
grande régate en effet au mois de
janvier dernier air des enfants du bénin
qui nous avait appelés parce qu'ils
savaient pas ils voulaient monter une
bibliothèque pour la mine n'est pas de
l'ironie foot s'étaient engagées alors
le donner du matériel scolaire des
livres nous envoyer une vidéo pour vous
remercier pour le montrer le résultat je
n'ai pas vu la vidéo à voir et à la
découvrir en sont
[Musique]
tottenham
c'est vrai j'avais jamais vu la vidéo
mais il m'a saoulé j'ai une vidéo j'ai
une vidéo j'ai une vidéo n'a pourtant
une dernière chose savaient que tpm pc
une famille et je crois que vous en avez
la preuve vous qui bien sûr j'en ai la
preuve une belle grande famille soudée
où tout le monde s'aime
et oui quand sincérité amour et quelques
piques au tour rim et bien c'est la tp
family on adore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors de leurs votes auront donné quoi si
c'est pas moi je me coupe une tare six
mois tu vas tubes à winneway dégueulasse
mais cherbourg
quand jen était beau mais avec l'âge
comme beaucoup d'hommes malheureusement
j'ai pris de l'embonpoint et j'ai pris
le pneu voilà donc pas malheureusement
j'habite pas clermont ferrand mais il ne
peut le montrer a déjà fait une
évolution alors
[Musique]
merci pq